مسيره طويله تنقلت خلالها بين عده وظائف
وعاشت ظروفا قاسيه كام عازبه تحمل عبء شئه
طفل صغير هذه التحديات واكثر عاشتها
الامريكيه دين هند ريكس قبل ان تصبح سيده
ذات قيمه اجتماعيه وتتربع على ثروه تقدر
بثلاثه عشر مليارا و700 مليون دولار فما
هي قصتها ولدت دايان هند ريكس عام
1947 في مزرعه البان بريف ولايه ويسكونسن
حيث كانت هذه المزرعه مصدر دخل العائله
كانت ديان واحده من ثمان بنات في بيئه
متعصبه ازاء عمل المراه خارج المنزل فكانت
احلامها لا تتجاوز ان تذهب يوما من الايام
للعمل في المدينه وترتدي زيا عصريا اثناء
دراستها بالمرحله الثانويه التقت ديان
بوالد طفلها الاول وتزوجته وهي لا تزال
فقط ما جعلها تعيش احدى اصعب تجارب حياتها
حيث حملت بطفلها الاول فدارست سنتها
الاخيره في المنزل بعد ان حصلت على شهاده
الثانويه وجد زوجها عملا في مصنع كرايسلر
بينما حصلت هي على وظيفه في مصنع اقلام ثم
انتقلت للعمل كنادله بسبب امومتها لم يكن
ايجاد الفرص المستقره سهلا مضطرها دائما
للتنقل بين الوظائف كما ان انفصالها عن
زوجها وتحولها لام مطلقه وهي في الحاديه
والعشرين من عمرها فقط زاد الطين بالله
بعد سنوات من التنقل استطاع الديان ان
تحصل على وظيفه جديده في بيع الانشاءات
واثناء ذلك درست للحصول على رخصه للعمل
كواسطه عقاريه قبل ان تلتقي بكنت هندريكس
الذي كان يملك شريكه لبناء الاسقف وتزوجت
منه لتتوحد اعمالهما معا في غضون ثلاث
سنوات العمل معا اشترى كان وديان ما يقرب
من مئه منزل قديم وتشاركا في ترميمها ومن
ثم بيعها ثم في عام
توحدت جهود كينوا ديان في شركه لبيع مواد
البناء هي شركه اي بي سي التي تديرها
اليوم وبدا في شراء متاجر لبيع منتجاتها
كما وسع نطاق عملهما بعد ان حصل على تمويل
بنكي افتتح الزوجان ثلاثه وثلاثين متجرا
في غضون ثلاث سنوات وبحلول عام
1986 توسعت الشركه الى خمسين متجرا وحققت
مبيعات بقيمه 183 مليون دولار بحلول عام
1994 نمت الشركه الى مئه متجر على مستوى
البلاد وبعد اربع سنوات وصلت مبيعاتها الى
مليار دولار في عام 2001 قام الزوجان
بتاسيس شركه هندرس اولدن كوو وهي شركه
تتراس مجموعه متنوعه من الاعمال كالتصنيع
والتوزيع والتطوير العقاري والبناء واعاده
التدوير وعلوم الحياه في عام 2007 حدث ما
لم يكن بالحسبان حيث تعرض للسقوط اثناء
قيامه بترميمات داخل منزله ما ادى الى
وفاته بعد ساعات من وصوله الى المستشفى
فاضطر الديان الى تحمل ثقل مشروع بمليارات
الدولارات وواجهت ازمات عده حيث تراجعت
المبيعات بنسبه عشره في المئه بين عامي
2006 و209 كما اغلقت الشركه ثلاثين متجرا
ليبقى لديها
350 متجرا اعادت هندرس ترتيب اوراق الشركه
واستطاعت ان تضمد الجراح واعادت العمل الى
المسار الصحيح عندما اتبع السياسه
الاستحواذ على اصول ثمانيه عشره شركه اخرى
وفرضت هيمنتها على السوق كما تمكنت من
امتلاك اكثر من 48 موقعا واثناء تلك
الفتره ايضا استطاع الديان اقتحام سوق
الانتاج الفني فوجدت طريقها الى هوليود
حيث انتجت عده افلام سينمائيه مثل سرايا
في مكانه يوما من الايام طفله تحلم بوظيفه
خارج الريف بات لديان هندرس اسم كبير في
سوق مواد البناء العالمي وتمتلك ثروه تقدر
بنحو 13 مليارا و700 مليون دولار جعلتها
اغنى سيده عصاميه امريكيه
[موسيقى]